[Musique]
au maire m'a tué on m'a mise en texte
entre il ya des odyssées c'est là que je
suis mort
[Musique]
pourtant mes premières expériences était
des plus modestes
on m'a invité au coin d'un feu je
passais de counter en conteur j'ai payé
enfants et adolescents de données
parfois des vocations jeu consoler les
coeurs meurtris
et puis tout est allé très vite
l'histoire du grand père j'ai été
propulsé en légende dorée jusqu'à
devenir la source de la culture
européenne
j'espère qu'un jour on ne ressusciteront
on comprendra qu'elle était ma raison
d'être ici bas sachez que le mythe se
dit plus qu'il ne se lit c'est la bouche
à l'oreille qui manie le voyage qui
m'ont endurci indomptables par nature je
suis un chat qui danse
[Musique]
non
blair
ja
à
[Musique]
le minotaure monstres mythologiques
moitié homme moitié toro avait droit
tous les neuf ans à sept jeunes
athéniens et cette jeune athénienne
livré en sacrifice face à cette barbarie
these héros athéniens décide d'affronter
minotaure pour mettre fin à cette
tradition
il sort victorieux de ce combat ait
réussi à sortir du labyrinthe avec
l'aide d'ariane la fille du roi de crète
minos et libère knossos de cet horrible
sort
[Musique]
voilà le récit qui devait se raconter un
peu partout sur les places publiques
dans les tavernes et les marchés antique
mais quelle crédibilité déjà chez les
grecs anciens pouvait-on lui accorder et
derrière la légende du minotaure peut-on
déceler une part de vérité
[Musique]
le site archéologique de knossos abrite
des bâtiments minoens daté d'il ya
environ quatre mille ans ce qui fait la
célébrité de ce lieu se sont en
particulier ses palais ses fresques et
le lieu supposé du labyrinthe du
minotaure qu'une hausse est une cité
entourée de mystère et de légendes minos
et pasiphaé à rien et aisée le minotaure
et labyrinthes re découverte en 1900 par
arthur evans anthropologue archéologues
anglais qui exhument avec son équipe un
édifice de 1200 pièces la cité sera très
vite associé au légendaire roi minos et
son labyrinthe mystérieux construit par
des dalles un dédale c'est justement le
terme pour décrire le parcours que
n'importe quel touriste expérimente en
étant pour la première fois les pieds
ici un enchaînement sans fin de couloir
d'escalier de cours à plusieurs entrées
et une fatigue qui vous touche assez
rapidement la difficulté de circulation
et d'orientation peut donc faire penser
à la forme labyrinthique vue du ciel
c'est assez flagrant mais ce plan est
finalement assez classique et on
retrouve cet agencement pour les autres
sites et de l'âge du bronze en
méditerranée sans parler
systématiquement d'un labyrinthe
ça
autre intérêt du site les fresques le
mobilier et les sculptures de l'or des
peintures représentant des minots à
moitié nue entourée de nourriture des
céramiques à foison et surtout des
représentations de taureaux l'édifice
qui a donc fait parler de lui au début
des fouilles et le palais ou mais
garonne qui veut dire grande salle c'est
un bâtiment très reconnaissable par des
façades monumentale et un foyer central
entouré de plusieurs colonnes tout
autour il ya des entrepôts des halls et
des couloirs d'accès à partir des objets
précieux et du mais on a voulu y voir le
palais des souverains de la crête
minoenne les grandes salles pouvait
accueillir le trône d'autres pièces des
fontaines et ben luxueux et puis plus
loin il y avait un théâtre appelé petit
palais qui offrait des spectacles et
notamment des tauromachies pour divertir
l'élite
c'est en tout cas la version qu'on a
donnée evans qui attribua à sa
découverte le nom de labyrinthe du
palais de knossos la renommée du site
était fait depuis les chercheurs sont
revenus sur cette première
interprétation un peu trop belle pour
être historique et tente de comprendre
la véritable fonction des palais minoen
visiblement le terme palais peut prêter
à confusion car rien ne prouve qu'il
s'agisse du lieu de vie des rois
ces grands édifices aurait tout aussi pu
assumer une fonction religieuse ou
funéraire en croit les objets exposés au
musée des racques lions très rares sont
ceux rattachés aux pratiques de la vie
courante
trop beau pas à ces pratiques et surtout
pas assez utilisé il est peut-être
facile de toujours choisir la piste du
religieux quand on n'a pas idée de la
fonction d'un lieu mais que nos sauces
n'est pas un cas unique
d'autres cités crétoise présente les
mêmes dispositifs architecturaux et sont
aussi richement doté festo ce asia
triade amalia à cros semblent avoir été
des centres religieux et pas des
résidences luxueuses pour souverain en
villégiature
[Musique]
avec ce nouvel angle de vue on peut
appréhender différemment que nos sauces
et voir dans ce matériel luxueux des
offrandes et faire de ces innombrables
pièces des salles de rituels de
cérémonie peut-être de préparation des
corps avant l'inhumation est un lieu de
recueillement des familles
on comprend ainsi mieux l'absence de
rempart de fossés ou deux tourelles
puisque personne n'attaque un lieu sacré
il est évident que la mythologie a
largement influencé evans et son équipe
d'archéologues à l'époque en 1900 en
exhumant le palais il est persuadé qu'il
s'agit de celui du roi minos plus qu'une
découverte archéologique majeure
cette mise au jour replacer dans son
contexte historique prend une valeur
philosophique retrouver le palais de
minos c'est aussi faire ressurgir le
mythe du minotaure
une thèse qui n'est pas vraiment au goût
de l'époque pour beaucoup de
scientifiques de la fin du 19e siècle et
du début du xxème
les histoires de sacrifices humains de
monstres fantastiques et anthropophage
n'avait rien de vrai semblables le
minotaure n'avait pas sa place dans la
pensée humaniste et n'était qu'un
symbole de la consécration de la grèce
hellénistique sur un culte archaïque
dans cette logique le labyrinthe n'était
plus qu'une simple invention d'un poète
grec à l'imagination débordante
bref pas de place dans le monde de la
science pour la barbarie même
mythologiques
le contexte tient donc une part
indéniable dans le déroulement des
fouilles de knossos qui se déroule
jusqu'à la fin de la seconde guerre
mondiale à la sortie de ce conflit
la redécouverte d'une civilisation riche
ce représentant sur les fresques nu
maquiller dans un lieux ensoleillés
tranche est fortement avec la crise
existentielle que venait de vivre
l'europe
le touriste de l'après-guerre qui
visitait knossos et les rivages de la
méditerranée ne pouvait pas faire de
nouveau face à ces cruautés passé celle
des sacrifices humains
il fallait taire le mythe du minotaure
les crétois des fresques anciennes était
un modèle d' existence insouciante loin
des camps de la mort
[Musique]
par des choix stylistiques de
restitution les fouilleurs ont mis en
avant un mythe celui de la royauté
prospère plutôt que celle du ninon tort
insatiable aujourd'hui quand on visite
une hausse
on a la sensation d'être dans un
disneyland archéologiques en béton pour
reprendre les mots du géologue l'une des
reliques les colonnes de béton du rouge
tape à l'oeil et des sculptures tout
propre c'est l esthétisme de l'époque
des vans de la belle époque
d'ailleurs la plupart des restitutions
architectural et artistique qu'à
commander evans sont aujourd'hui
contestée par l'archéologie finalement
qu avons nous appris à klaus qu'il n'ya
malheureusement pas de preuve de
l'existence d'un homme toro dommage mais
aussi que ce qui est aujourd'hui
présenté comme un labyrinthe en
référence aux aventures de taizé rien
d'autre qu'un plan classique de grands
complexes de l'antiquité que ce soit en
asie mineure en mésopotamie
en egypte des salles étroite car
difficiles à couvrir sans recourir à des
voûtes procès des inconnus à cette
époque d'ailleurs des presque de
taureaux encore une fois il n'ya rien de
plus commun en méditerranée et ce dès le
plus ancien néolithique soit des
millénaires avant que nos sources
enfin si on laisse de côté l'idée de
ligne ou tort il n'est même pas sûre que
ce lieu était un palais royal ou en tout
cas il n'a pas été que cela
le mythe à don total ont déformé notre
vision du site obnubilé par cette
histoire fameuse nous voulons y trouver
ce que nous connaissons déjà
quitte à oublier sa réalité plus
complexe c'est un risque auquel d'autres
le mythique n'échappe pas et nous
verrons st dans le prochain épisode
[Musique]